thank you very much yes sir i'm here
with the number one romanian player
uh in the world constantin lupulescu
constantine first of all
what an amazing victory what an amazing
comeback after yesterday's loss
take us through the game and first of
all tell us how you feel right now
yeah great great when okay a bit shocked
because
somehow i was worse and then suddenly
suddenly
i came back and okay he missed i think
he missed queen f7
is this the victory against the highest
rated player yeah
yeah yeah that's amazing take us through
the game let's start from the beginning
did he surprise you with his opening
choice um not really so
okay he played some games so far so
queen c2 i was not sure where he's going
to go so bishop c3
queen c3 queen is seven this was all
normal
d4 knight e4 queen d3 d4
knight d4 knight c5 queen d1 94
queen d4 you are still in your
preparation yeah still in my preparation
but somehow here i underestimated
all his idea i thought it's just nothing
but actually i was also not doing much
so bishop p2b6
sure castle bishop b7 f3a5
we were discussing this position and we
weren't sure whether f3 was necessarily
the practical choice
just because you kind of imbalance the
position of the structure a little bit
and create some weaknesses okay if i see
something that you prepared
um i knew this idea i didn't actually
prepare this okay of course if i want to
play it very safe
after bishop e2 b6 i can just go
bishop f3 swap the bishops and
black never has attacked but then um my
winning chances are
very slim to none yeah so i thought okay
i should keep a pair of bishops and then
see what happens
but actually i was not doing the right
things here so bishop i don't know
exactly what i did wrong
maybe somewhere i went i was too slow
because then um maybe some rook a1 and
bishop d1 bishop c3 some another regular
pig
what i found was not the best for sure
well somehow the position already
doesn't feel that
comfortable yeah yeah my bishops are not
doing much
this is a problem and he has very easy
moves he can always this knight is very
annoying on
c5 he can go knight e6 anytime he likes
and he can prepare
what happened in the game like rook f6
and some attacking idea
did you feel at any point that you're
losing control of the game yeah
um actually after queen f7
so here so okay here look f2
rook f6 and here i decided to bail out i
said okay constantly one second
we know we have a result right now in uh
the book down there game against
mamedyarov
that game ended in a draw let's continue
okay so here i've
decided to bail out i said okay enough
it's enough
so i played this bishop e3 after of
course if he just swaps it's
completely equal and queen of seven he
probably has a little panicking this
rookie toy totally missed
his queen h5 and the piece on e4 idea
ah so i don't know g6 but i think now
it's very easy to play
it's not so easy for me to defend here
definitely not
not i couldn't find okay all the time if
i can play
if i play h3 then i risk a lot i i was
not sure so i saw this regrouping
for a long time this bishop one i tried
to make it work but actually it was
quite dubious so
q5 bishop e1
and he played bishop e4 um
were you worried about other moves yeah
actually some bishop f3 ideas i was
bishop takes f3 not immediately sorry so
something like night how is it
night knight 34 seems to be a very uh
interesting 94 was
also what didn't look so good um and 96
i have queen h4 i don't remember exactly
how we could make and another way
that the computer was showing i think
was to play either rook h6 or rock g6
four should go bishop g3 and now knight
to e4
oh an already very difficult move such
as c5 to uh
keep the balance well save yourself on
some degree
yeah this looks quite bad yeah but he
played this move bishop e4 did
uh he surprised you with this move yeah
okay i only considered knight
so bishop b4 came as a surprise but i
think a pleasant surprise because i
thought
okay now i'm somehow swapping some
pieces i'm not doing so bad
and bishop b1 because bishop c2 i was
afraid of this line kind of 96
and um queens let's say back queen d2
and takes and takes and knight 35 but
probably it was just nothing yeah
somehow yeah it was not doing copy shops
are still uh yeah
yeah yeah king h1 bishop g3 it doesn't
seem like he's getting anywhere
have a lot of pieces around your kings
yeah so this was not uh
probably this was better so bishop e1 we
thought bishop b1 is a very
natural also looked natural yes rook g6
and bishop g3 bishop b1 rook b1
and finally my real contribution in the
game after 94 i
found this idea with with queen f7
because i had to see it in
advance otherwise it's quite bad so i
think this was a
brilliant defense yes so rookie one and
uh knight g3
25 i need because otherwise he returns
with the queen just pawn down
so queen d5 king h8 hg3 rook g3
e4 and okay he was playing for some
tricks because for example
queen f3 and if if he looks winning then
just
loses in one moves but of course i saw
this queen f7
and i thought here for sure i'm not
worse and he looks
quite uh yeah h6 i thought he could play
h6 and i think i wanted to play
something like king h1 and uh
this would probably end in a draw
he should probably repeat already
because it looks very dangerous
do you think he uh just wanted to beat
you at all
costs and took unnecessary risks i think
yeah
he i think his approach was not so
practical because
he was already in big time trouble so i
think maybe also for him it was
time to bail out yeah because he kind of
lost control i think with
he already was approaching i think he
had
around three minutes on the clock left
and that was
very risky what he did were you
surprised about his time spencer
uh specifically given that it felt like
his position is a bit more comfortable
to play
um well a bit surprised but actually he
found this
very good idea so with the queen f7 and
uh
so he found some good moves so there
were some some
he spent the time wisely yeah wisely but
now i think it was already time to bail
out
so he did quincy six uh
now okay i'm already playing for a win i
thought because i have some ideas like
h6 f6 and let's say if queen c5 already
queen g8 is winning
and this was your idea in the game yeah
the actual game as well
actually yeah yeah so quincy five and
okay he's already
playing for tricks okay rook eight i saw
rook g2
i cannot take but okay this is just a
draw yes but of course i saw i can play
for more so quincy five
and rookie seven yeah and here i
couldn't
really see a difference for him i don't
know if there is probably not no
it's game over at this point yes rook t4
okay
f6 i think it's spoiling things because
okay he has an object
with checks and then and here okay
of course of course i repeat moves once
because i also
very short on time i'll ask for okay
this is blunder but probably it's not
the blunder with it was still
with the broke up yeah yes so okay so
queen h3
yeah and here i had to i was
i think i had to be yeah maybe i thought
maybe anything it's winning but but then
it's dangerous because then
you end up playing the move that doesn't
win so finally i found this idea okay
look this is a huge victory for you but
more importantly what does it
mean for you to play after one year and
a half of inactive
inactivity against all these top players
of the world
okay frankly unbelievable i mean
i really didn't expect this i was i was
just
no sitting at home and then then this
tournament show up
sitting at home and after that winning
in brilliant style congratulations
thank you kostika and we'll we're
looking forward to see you
next games thank you guys back to you